from jazz to pop traditional to
contemporary dance is about
self-expression and with each self comes
a different interpretation spanning
continents and backgrounds dance we've
seen is not one-size-fits-all
it says diverse as the people performing
it so we're looking back and
re-examining what dance looks like
[Music]
people say that like oh like we're doing
this because black girls can do ballet
so this is the alternative it has
nothing to do with that Hitler is a
mixture of hip-hop and ballet it just
gives you confidence and it's just a
freedom to be yourself
I'm known I guess to be a man that
dances in heels dance was like my way of
screaming pretty much it can't be this
way treble dancers if you not like that
in your life
the way I dance is the way I am
[Music]
I've always been really interested in
how dance can be taken off the stage
then that maybe it could be used for
something more than just for myself so
I'm bringing dance to this refugee camp
as a therapy to dance is this really
amazing vessel for which healing can
take place because it involves
physicality and connecting with yourself
in your body people something Polly
he the magnetizing is a woman is look
like trick I just ignore the criticism I
turns this schematic dance named Nina
tower turns and when I perform this
transform and I prove to the society
that I can do this kind of transform the
best for me preserving tradition is
important because the tradition is
identity of the country
[Music]
number railroads samskaara dahana 38
heap item area I trow like a level
editor but in telomere a cotillion with
a singaporean until a guru
protego prank TC fedoras and blood on
the the erector are like a failure and
the my necessary room cuz I've included
are fidgety in Europe and born in an
energy wisdom comes eligible to become
heavily at the world and the G with
onion garlic
[Music]
[Applause]
we can upper release first thing you
thinking about logistics moko Jumbies is
life in general at the view I feel a
sense of pride and sometimes feel like
Shay naughty now a sense of bringing
everyone together hula is the language
of the heart and therefore the heartbeat
of the Hawaiian people and we tell our
dancers everything needs that
[Music]
the biggest misconception about hula is
that it's easy all hula dancers and you
quote me on this have bad knees all of
them you have blisters on your feet if
you can bend your knees and swing your
hips and have this upper body carriage
that's really upgrade but make it look
effortless that's not true
you know I don't dance hula just to be a
missile Ola I do it because I just
because I love it and I I kind of
explain to you why I do I think it's
something you're just born with
[Music]
you
[Music]